wow kim's one of the best you're lucky
to have her
she sure is we sure are seems like just
yesterday she was logging hours in dock
review
always a pleasure to see one of our
proteges spread her wings and leave the
nest
in the lead up to the final season a
better call saul there was a trend where
i saw a lot of pro howard hamlin post
pop up you saw titles like am i the only
one who thinks howard is a good guy or
howard doesn't deserve what's happening
to him everywhere as the final season
continues i see a ton of questions about
why kim and jimmy are doing what they're
doing so today i thought i would look at
their reasoning i believe there's some
interesting stuff going on here and it
might turn out to be crucial for each of
these characters endings for spoilers if
you haven't watched the first five
seasons of better call saul then this
video probably isn't for you
if the question is but why howard the
first thing to consider is what jimmy
and kim are trying to accomplish
howard's firm hhm is leading the
class-action suit against sandpiper
crossing they operate a number of
assisted living facilities across the
country and jimmy discovered that they
were ripping off their elderly clients
these types of suits take years to
settle and that means that jimmy won't
get his seven-figure payment anytime
soon sam piper has already offered to
make a settlement but as is standard hhm
and davis and maine turned it down so
they can negotiate for more kim has
decided that she wants to chase her
dream of opening a pro bono practice to
help the less fortunate get the same
representation as the wealthy and sees
jimmy's payout as a way to make this
happen right now if they can do
something to bring howard's reputation
into question that would put pressure on
the firms to settle immediately to avoid
any public relations scandals that might
make things difficult she also believes
that she can work things out and plan
things so that it will damage him but
not ruin his career of course kim and
jimmy have history with howard they both
work for him at hhm so he's the most
logical target to go after and i think
it's fair to ask the question why not
howard there's nothing particularly
noble or good about who he is he's the
face of the firm that his father started
most of what we see him do involves
keeping up appearances with clients and
eating lunch at fork there's no
indication that he's an exceptional
attorney most of hhn's reputation for
that appeared to stem from chuck's work
who also believed he was responsible for
the firm's growth and success no one
really seems to dispute that the history
is important even if the part about
jimmy comes with an asterisk in the
first episode of better call saul jimmy
learns from chuck that howard would like
him to stop using the name mcgill for
his law practice his own name this is
just one of a series of injustices which
include not hiring jimmy after he passed
a bar exam you do find out later that
chuck was behind all of this that's
where the asterisk comes in but howard
willingly went along to keep his partner
happy what's more part of his
frustration from that came out in the
way that he dealt with kim and this may
have extended to other employees kim
worked her way up through the mail room
she got help from the firm for law
school she passed the bar and then got
hired on to become one of their best up
and coming associates when she wasn't
able to convince the kettlemans to take
the very good deal she worked out for
them howard punished her by sending her
to doc review in the basement this
happens again in the second season after
the davidson main commercial incident
this seemed excessive but even though
jimmy wanted to fight back kim decided
to fix it her own way the right way she
tried to bring in a new client to get
back on the firm's good side she worked
on her own time and landed mesa verde
but howard was still reluctant to return
her to her old position eventually she
decided to leave hhm to start her own
practice and that led to a battle over
mesa verde where howard and chuck tried
their best to retain the client
so that's most of the early setup and in
the beginning of the series there was a
lot not to like about howard even though
most of the crazy stuff with jimmy was
chuck's fault where i think things start
to get interesting is after his death
particularly when kim goes to pick up
the check from chuck's estate in that
exchange she lays into howard for being
insensitive to what jimmy's going
through and this is the first time where
we see that she has something bubbling
under the surface in relation to her old
boss there's a cathartic element for her
but there's a couple of other things of
note here first is that she's protective
of her partner in a pretty fierce way
and the second is that howard sees her
point he even says what can i do to make
it right this marks the beginning of
when we start to see another side of
howard because chuck was such an
imposing character and business partner
most of what howard did was react to him
when he finally stood up and forced him
into retirement he killed himself in the
wake of that howard was saddled with
guilt but after hitting a real low point
he was able to turn things around in
that time he became sympathetic so when
at the end of season 5 kim brings up her
plan even jimmy doesn't think he
deserves what she has in mind i think
the timing of things explains a lot and
his approaching her at the courthouse in
the season 5 finale is the event that
set things into motion the exchange
highlights a lot of what's going on i
guess before i go through the ways that
set kim off i should mention that it
also works to keep howard likeable since
he's coming from a place of genuine
concern for jimmy he believes he needs
help based on the bowling ball and
prostitutes showing up at lunch
incidents and the lightning bolts shoot
from my fingertips tirade at the
courthouse how he approaches kim is
where he goes wrong he not only implies
that she doesn't know what's going on
with her partner but that he must be
manipulating her because her decision to
walk away from schweikert and coakley
doesn't make sense to him so he
questions her ability to make her own
decisions and he activated her sense of
wanting to protect jimmy even if what
he's saying about him is true kim knows
him and doesn't feel like she needs
howard to swoop in and help to explain
what's going on and i mentioned the
timing this is immediately after his
trip to the desert they're still hiding
out at the hotel and when she goes back
there jimmy suggests that maybe they
should just go home she can see that
he's not out of the woods as far as his
ptsd and you see her shift into this
space where she's trying to figure out
how to make him feel better throughout
the series we've seen that pulling a con
is something that brings them closer
together and i think that plays a part
in her coming up with this idea as they
eat and talk she brings it up and
notices that it gets his attention plus
it's justifiable if they can pull it off
they'll get the money for the pro bono
practice in her mind that would help a
lot of people she can get back at howard
for personal reasons and she can maybe
bring jimmy back from this dark place
he's in it starts to work and they come
together and by the time jimmy tries to
pull back kim just takes that as a cue
that she'll need to take charge she does
that and that's pretty much how things
got started i think there's more to it
that will come out in the next handful
of episodes to me it seems like there's
something from her past that makes her
resent people like howard where he came
from and the world they inhabit together
we've had a few glimpses into her past
and know that she worked really hard to
get to where she's at i feel like even
in her accomplishments there was a sense
of disappointment there that's popped up
over the past few seasons she threw
herself into the pro bono work trying to
make the other stuff make sense and when
that didn't work she decided to walk
away completely i do think that howard
works as a symbol of all of what she
finds distasteful about this situation
his story is basically the polar
opposite of hers and that's why she's
more motivated to take him down than
jimmy is
i think the scene where she cuts him to
check for her tuition after running into
him at lunch is a great example of that
coming out and i don't think the
connection kim and jimmy have as
outsiders in that world should be
overlooked either
to wrap things up it's not weird to like
howard and not want him to get destroyed
at this stage in the game he started out
unlikable and in my opinion is still not
remarkable but patrick fabian does sell
the performance also the writers started
to make him sympathetic at the same time
the other characters were starting to do
awful things that weren't as easy to
overlook in some ways he looks great i
suppose at this point i'd feel bad if
something happens to him but i'm still
rooting for kim and jimmy because that's
how i am and i think that's a good place
to leave things let me know in the
comments what you think about howard how
we got to where we are and how this plan
is going to go down please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon